Bruce Wayne's been kicking butt for
justice for 75 years
here's your DC all-access guide to the
top ten badass Batman moments what list
would be complete without Batman's epic
battle against Superman from Dark Knight
Returns not only does Bruce defeat the
Blue Boy Scout but his chilling speech
must have echoed and Supes his ears long
after I want you to remember Clark in
your most private moments I want you to
remember the one man who beat you our
next moment comes from the classic tale
Joker's five-way revenge to save an
innocent life Batman allows Joker to
handcuff him and dump him into a tank
with a massive shark predictably the
final score is Bruce one shark zero our
number eight pick comes from all the way
back in Batman issue 244 where Bruce
clashes with Ra's al Ghul in a deadly
sword fight when Batman is bitten by a
scorpion ra's wrongly assumes he's dead
allowing bats to finally end his reign
of terror extra points for our sexy hero
going shirtless while still wearing the
cape and cowl number seven comes from
the classic Arkham Asylum graphic novel
Joker has Bruce trapped in the asylum
with no way out alone and on the brink
of madness Batman stabs his own hand to
stay focused like a boss when facing the
court of owls in Batman number 2
Bruce busts out a high window while
fighting for his life against the talent
the only thing that saves in is his
knowledge of a hidden gargoyle built
into the side of Wayne tower because no
one knows Gotham like Batman this one is
for all the couples out there for the
pages of hush Batman saves Catwoman from
a deadly attack by Killer Croc then
makes his move on the rooftop just
because you're a grown man dressed like
a bat doesn't mean you can't also be a
ladies man next up our second classic
moment from The Dark Knight Returns a 60
year old Batman confronts the vicious
mutant gang leader and takes him to
school in a hand-to-hand fight in a mud
pit but this isn't just about defeating
the leader
it's about all the mutants seeing him to
feed the leader Batman simultaneously
wins himself an army while proving he's
the only true badass of Gotham Grant
Morrison's Rock of Ages storyline set
the current members of the Justice
League into apocalyptic future where
Darkseid has enslaved the earth in our
number three pick the Batman from this
future world agrees to help the Justice
League stop the apocalypse from ever
happening even though it means the
destruction of his entire world he
sacrifices everyone and everything for
the greater good without a second
thought
rest in peace apocalyptic future goofs
our number two comes from the iconic
graphic novel The Killing Joke at the
very end of the book Batman has Joker
trapped the Clown Prince of Crime tells
one last joke and Batman cracks a smile
it's unexpected and the perfect end a
comic dooms greatest hero villain
relationship our number one most badass
Batman moment isn't a battle or a twist
ending it's from Detective Comics 33
later retold in the pages of Batman year
one and Batman zero year in short Bruce
declares I shall become of that because
I mean what's more badass than Bruce
deciding he must become the Batman those
were our picks but we want to know what
you think with Batman's finest hour let
us know your greatest Batman moment on
using the hashtag DC oh and don't forget
we're celebrating Batman's 75th
anniversary all month long tip right
over there if you want even more Dark
Knight goodness yeah and subscribe right
here to DC all-access never missing
members